hello hello welcome to my car you're now
virtual passengers
today steven we're doing savory pie
an episode i'm very excited to do which
is why
i'm in the car picking up the pies to
bring to you
guys all right well today on worth it
we're going to be trying three savory
pies at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at its price
a savory pie is like a chicken pot pie
we're also talking about
small hand-held pies and in some parts
of the world when they say pie they mean
three point one four
one five nine two something something
something
keep going popeye is one of my favorite
foods and when you got that
flaky crust oh buttery crust our first
pie
is going to be of the hand-held variety
we're seeing winston
at his food truck saraba who specializes
in
belizian garifuna cuisine and we're
having his
[Music]
panatas
[Music]
my name is winston miranda from sarawak
garifuna cuisine
my food is typically from hormone
culture which is a girlfriend of people
my answer is they came from a part of
south africa in sierra leone and it
migrated to saint vincent from saint
vincent they went to honduras from
honduras and went to
belize our food is very unique we have
one that we call
the hudu which is like a staple food
that we eat every
day the fishermen will go to the sea and
bring the fish in and then refry it
they'll season the coconut milk and get
a flavor off of it
and add the fish to it and boil some
planting and then they will mash it so
you can get real smooth
and put it like a ball and then you eat
it with the coconut milk
the panares is a it's like an appetizer
most americans call it like
american hot pockets and he could be
eating any time in the early in the
morning
late at night midday we take the masa
and then we use the achote and believe
they call it ricardo is a red face
and the muscle will turn from white to
red then people say oh yeah he's making
authentic bananas just by the color when
people look at it you could do it with
fish you could do it with chicken
and you could do it with beans flatten
it up and then we fry
as a habanero onion sauce i can make it
spicy and i can make it non-spicy
late at night when i'm doing like clubs
and all that stuff people are drunk
so they want the hot hot one the hot
habanero sauce so
that'll wake them up saraba means wake
up
oh yeah that's what it means wake up
oh the smell is a really good
it kind of smells like fritos oh whoa
is this the shape you think of when you
think of pie when i think about pie i
think
autumn i think leaves pumpkin pie that's
the classic pie
i love how the outside looks like the
crust of a really good pizza
cheers cheers
mmm it's interesting how tightly the
seafood is wrapped
it's like tightly wound around the dough
which i really like
yeah and then you just have like the fin
of crust around the outside
kind of like a fish like a stegosaurus
oh sure like a fish
i want onion relish yeah let's go onion
relish
mmm oh yeah yeah that's
perfect just a nice vinegar bath going
across that thing
oh man oh yeah oh oh wow and a little
spicy
man flavored combinations it tastes very
similar
to squeezing lime on a taco
you know that super satisfying power
washing
videos yeah i don't know why but i was
just reminded of those
no that that totally makes sense it's
like when a liquid is
sharp when i first opened the box i was
like
wow you get a lot of these now i'm like
should have doubled it
i'm gonna do one more i'm going to be
talking about that onion sauce till the
day i die
i thought it was a mistake how much
onion stuff we got
actually but it was so good i was
shoveling it into my mouth
i'm ready for a savory pie fact savory
pie fact
the first known usage of sweetie pie
dates from 1928 1928 that seems pretty
late for sweetie pie that might have
been revolutionary like pewdiepie
whoa i'm more of a savory pie myself but
you can call me a sweetie pie
sweetie pie is something that i call my
cat actually
yeah is he a little sweetie pie he is a
little sweetie pie does he do that thing
where he like stops there next to you
he'll drop and like kind of go on his
belly and roll around what is that about
like what does that mean by the way
it means that they um are a sweetie pie
oh okay got it for our next savory pie
we're visiting natalia
at woodspoon to try her brazilian
chicken pot pie
we're also going to have their
house-made sangria
[Music]
with spoons serve a traditional food
from milo gerais
where i'm from we have a lot to to offer
in terms of
our culinary but we are very simple but
our flavor was very unique
i was born and raised in brazil when i
got here of course it was very hard for
me because
not speaking any english at all you know
i didn't understand why you're going to
to the beach with an outfit on you know
why can you get in a bus in a bikini why
you don't
go and get fresh eggs from somewhere or
there is fresh chicken from some places
the way we do in brazil is a little
different than here because you have the
privilege to buy just a particular type
of meat
then my mom will make a whole chicken
here i was able to
buy chicken thai we have to clean them
one by one
removing all the fats unnecessary pieces
that is there to make sure it's nice and
clean i save the broth
and i use the fat that stays above
to make the roux add the hearts of palm
corn
olives hearts of foam is a heart of a
palm tree
and it is a particular one brazil we can
actually get there
like they can be this tall this big
but here we only get the very small
parts of it
corn we had it everywhere in the
backyard where we planted ourselves
olives because you know we are
portuguese brazil is a country
with all countries in it you know people
get surprised
how we have the biggest japanese
community in the world as in brazil
there's more
lebanese in brazil than lebanon like we
have you know all in my town i mean as a
lot of chinese because the agriculture
the farming
we have stroganoff the german dish we
have
all these incredible cultures and
gastronomy
in brazil that i felt like open wood
spoon
will give me an opportunity to show a
little bit more
what brazil can offer i just wanted to
people to know brazil
not just the postcard but also into
those little cultures that it's so rich
and so real and so important this is my
home
whatever we can do for people to educate
themselves
to the food i believe food is a bridge
that connects
us all and this is mine okay fellas
welcome to the next pie i'm ready we
have two
house-made sangrias the red sangria we
have
citruses we have black pepper we have
cinnamon
and a little bit of a touch of a secret
and then we have
in the white wine a base of the passion
fruit
passion fruit chardonnay you know what
it is it's an
in-between color look at that those are
the best colors
some lights it's one thing others it's
another cheers oh my god
these louise that should be illegal
okay now just a little of the red
ho lee smokes
this is the best ingredient i've ever
had so check out this pie
that spoon oh i didn't even see the
spoon
oh oh my goodness oh
that's perfect that is that is really
perfect buttery
chicken i was also a little bit
surprised that there were olives in this
pot pie but it doesn't taste
overly olivey you know when you meet
somebody and you're just like
we're gonna be best friends i've never
met you before but the connection is
there the chemistry
like something about you and me would
just get along and i have never
met this chicken pot pie before but i
already know
i already know you it's like an old
baseball mitt it has this like
supple familiarity supple do you want us
the sauce wait sauce what sauce is green
sauce on the side oh i put that in the
salad
the thick sauce you put the thick sauce
in the salad
i didn't know it's so american of you
you see that thick dairy
and you're like that's gotta go on a
salad
oh that reminds me of the sangria that
we just had like
three minutes ago yes it does it's
smooth but also a little spicy
i really thought that the onion sauce
from shiraba was gonna be the last thing
that blew my mind today but
no
by the way i slept very well last night
yeah ryzen pie
hey uh roll us a pie fact
no wait that doesn't make sense vegas i
was thinking about the crust
bake is a pie fact it's estimated that
australia consumes
270 million meat pies every year
approximately 12 per person you're
telling me every australian
eating one meat pie every month of the
year in comparison new zealand
only consumes 66 million meat pies per
year but
with their much smaller population that
equates to 15 pies
per person every year
15 per year for the kiwis why are they
called kiwis we should be calling them
pies
[Laughter]
funny that we're mentioning australian
savory pies because the next pie
is actually inspired in pie australian
savory pie we're seeing
chef ryan at kispaka we're going to be
trying their
bone marrow pie
izapaka has been described as a meat
speakeasy by jonathan gold
this dish represents trying to take a
classic meat dish australian meat pie
and really trying to do it the best
of its possibilities so first step is
making a veal stock roasted veal bones
simmering for about six to eight hours
we cut up beef cheek into little pieces
and then we salt them and let it sit
overnight that allows for the salt to
actually penetrate the meat itself
when you have a stew or a braised meat
and the meat isn't seasoned ahead of
time you can tell
the meat is just being covered up by a
salty liquid you get nice caramelization
on the outside of it
and heavy caramelization we then take
that out the pan and add chipotle and
onions simply i mean it really just
means little onion
in italian and butt mushrooms with a
little bit of thyme and garlic so we
want to get the same color
on those vegetables as we do on the meat
the reason we do that separate is
because they cook at different
temperatures in different speeds
we deglaze with the fortified veal stock
bring the meat in and let meat cook for
about two hours or so beef cheek
is something that most people don't use
but it works amazing because you're
braising it and beef cheek has a lot of
connective tissue
it breaks down and makes it so you have
this beautiful mouth feel to the sauce
and the meat itself is tender we put the
vegetables in for the last hour if we
put the vegetables in the very beginning
they would just dissolve
roll out just a savory pie dough and the
top pie we cut a little circle so the
bone marrow actually can fit through
we sell them both baked off like ready
to go to eat or
you can take it home and bake it you've
actually probably sold more raw pies
when you have cooked pies we actually
are happy about that because when you
bake a pie
you want to eat it right away or the
texture from the bone marrow the
fattiness of the bone marrow
with the stew it almost sounds good to
be overwhelming you know kind of
why do you need that people call bone
marrow meat butter it adds this anxious
texture it's really really delicious
[Music]
look at this pie there's something
strange yet beautiful about a
bone protruding from crust you know what
it looks like right
it looks like some flintstones oh i
don't know it looks like a belly button
the fact that you bring this one home
and heat it up so your own house can get
filled with that aroma
oh my god let's let's dig in oh my god
what oh why is it so gooey
i can't wait come on
i'm so glad i'm not at peace baca right
now eating this the noise is coming out
of my mouth
we'd be causing a scene let's do busted
bone marrow so the last two pies that we
had
were accompanied by some of the greatest
sauces of this one the sauce comes
right in the middle you just scoop it
out
oh get out of here bathe my mouth i
never thought that a beef stew
would need to add more soft moistness to
it
it's out of this world the last thing i
want to say about this look at that meat
well fellas time to say pie pie for now
i became a pie
today and uh it's a good life steven
which
savory pie was the most worth it to you
at its price
all these pies i think tied for me so i
had to give it to the best sauce
am i worth it winner i'm going with
saraba today the onion sauce
lee smokes what about you gosh i love
pie quispaka
i think most high-end food is
not as good taken away as it would be
eaten in the restaurant but that pie i
think is a great example one that's
maybe even better eaten at home my worth
at winter goes to wood spoon
i love chicken pot pie that pot pie was
perfect and i loved it
adam what a winner wood spoon by the way
what pants are you wearing right now
because i'm wearing sweatpants because i
knew
this would be a heavy pie day so yeah
i'm wearing shorts with a drawstring and
it
is not tied
[Music]
you